well we knew it was going to end up in
front of the Supreme Court at some point
but scotus may decide this sooner rather
than later and that's good news for some
and bad news for others now Donald Trump
basically says that the constitution
gave him absolute power to do whatever
he wanted as president and without
criminal prosecution then I have an
article to where I have the right to do
whatever I want as president and former
president Trump has asked an appeals
court to dismiss one of the criminal
indictments against him because of this
alleged presidential immunity but
special Council Jack Smith has now
answered Trump's claim with a petition
for sor that might as well be entitled
that's not how this works that's not how
any of this works and Smith doesn't want
to waste any time he wants the Supreme
Court to decide this issue without
waiting around for an appell at decision
so can Trump be tried convicted and
punished for acts he committed while
president or is he absolutely immune
from federal prosecutions for these
alleged crimes and what is the Supreme
Court going to do about it now in August
1st 2023 a Federal grand jury in
Washington DC entitled Donald Trump on
four counts of attempting to interfere
in the 2020 election the indictment
alleges that while Trump was still
president he participated in a
conspiracy to defraud the United States
that he corruptly obstructed the
certification of the presidential
election results on January 6 2021 and
that he conspired with other people to
do the same and that he violated one or
more person's constitutional rights to
vote and have their vote counted the
federal district court judge Tanya
chuckin scheduled the trial to begin on
March 4th 2024 but Trump recently filed
a motion to dismiss the indictment on
the grounds that he has absolute
immunity from Criminal prosecution for
acts taken within the Outer Perimeter of
His official responsibilities and that
the indictments allegations all fall
within that scope Trump also argue the
double jeopardy principles and the
impeachment Clause barred his
prosecution Smith opposed Trump's motion
on the grounds that the president does
not have absolute immunity from Federal
Criminal prosecution The District Court
denied Trump's immunity claim and
rejected the impeachment Clause argument
Trump filed a notice of appeal to the DC
circuit and moved for stay of all
proceedings in the district court while
his appeal was pending and under federal
law and Supreme Court precedent an
appeal suspends trial proceedings
specifically anything quote involved in
the appeal so I think in an abundance of
caution judge chuckin has now halted
most aspects of the case although we
don't know EX exactly how much of the
case has halted and for how long Trump's
Appeal on the immunity issue is an
interlocutory appeal an interlocutory
appeal is an appeal to the court of
appeals before a conviction or a
sentence and federal procedure States
quote the filing of a notice of appeal
confers jurisdiction on the courts of
appeal and divest The District Court of
its control over those aspects of the
case involved in the appeal so
consequently judge Chuck's order pauses
any further proceedings that would move
the case towards trial or impose
additional burdens of litigation on
defendant however her order is limited
in two respect first the state deadlines
and proceedings are held in abeyance
rather than permanently vacated and
judge tuck said she would release the
marched trial date if jurisdiction were
returned to her second the Court's other
protective measures are not in abayance
which means that Trump still has to
follow his pre-trial release conditions
and the judge's gag orders the judge
also said her protective orders uh
guiding Discovery and jury procedures
are still active and it's theoretically
possible the entire criminal prosecution
Trump is not necessarily stay there's
case law stating that an appeal only
divests the federal court over control
of as I said those aspects of the case
involved in the appeal here that could
mean the rest of the case continues to
move forward but as judge chuckin notes
there is no circuit precedent on the
Court's protective orders quote much
less instructive cases in the context of
an interlocutory immunity appeal the
Supreme Court recently stay an
arbitration case in its entirety because
quote the question on appeal is whether
the case belongs in arbitration or
instead in District Court the entire
case is essentially involved in the
appeal so here we don't know exactly
what a claim of presidential immunity
will do to the case as a whole but
clearly there will be delays in some
respects now obviously you're going to
want a good lawyer to argue in front of
the Supreme Court but if you want a
great lawyer my firm the eagle team can
help if you've been in a car crash
suffered a data breach or have a
workers's comp or Social Security
Disability issue we can represent you or
help find you the right attorney who can
It's always important to talk to a
lawyer right away so you can get the
best representation and find out what
your options are so just click on the
link in the description for free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team link is below but rather
than wait for the appeals court to rule
Smith filed a petition for for Sora
requesting that the Supreme Court
expedite Trump's appeal from the
district court order and Trump opposes
this motion even though he wants the
case dismissed now if this appeal goes
forward on an ordinary or even expedited
timeline the Supreme Court would not
decide it until probably next term in
2025 and barring something completely
unforeseen Trump will be the Republican
party's nominee for president then if
Trump is elected he might argue that the
case can't move forward because sitting
presidents can't be prosecuted or he
might just dismiss the case himself so
the first question is can Smith bypass
the court of appeals uh trp world has
reacted to Smith's move with the typical
understatement for example quote crooked
Joe Biden's henchman deranged Jack Smith
is so obsessed with interfering in the
2024 presidential election with the goal
of preventing president Trump from
retaking the Oval Office as the
president is poised to do that Smith is
willing to try for a Hail Mary by racing
to the Supreme Court and attempting to
bypass the appell at process but in
opposing the government's motion Trump
complains that it took too long for the
government to prosecute him so now the
court should take as long as possible to
dismiss the case against him quote the
prosecution waited over 2 years to bring
this Lawless case and then sought an
extraordinarily expedited trial calendar
demanding the jury selection begin in
December 2023 not withstanding there is
a process by which the Supreme Court can
weigh in before an appeals court renders
a decision federal law says quote an
application for the Supreme Court for a
RIT of curite to review a case before
judgment has been rendered in the court
of appeals may be made at any time
before judgment and when is it okay to
ask for an expedited review of this type
well when quote the cas is of such
imperative public importance as to
justify deviation from normal appell
practice and to require immediate
determination in the court and rather
than being a liberal conspiracy it's a
process by which the Supreme Court can
issue a decision without having to wait
for the lower court of appeals often
when things are incredibly important for
the country and also when it doesn't
make any sense to wait for the court of
appeals if the Supreme Court is going to
have the final word on the decision
anyway Smith argues that this is
obviously a case of imperative public
importance the amenability to criminal
prosecution of a former president of the
United States for conduct undertaken
during his presidency it requires no
extended discussion to confirm that this
case involving charges that respondents
sought to thwart the peaceful transfer
of power through violations of federal
criminal law is at the Apex of public
importance the charges implicate a
central tenant of our democracy and
there is some precedent to support the
idea of the Court acting quickly to
resolve a claim of presidential immunity
as the government wrote in its briefing
quote when the government sought cior
before judgment in the United States
versus Nixon a case presenting similarly
consequential issues of presidential
privilege the court granted the petition
and resolved the Constitutional question
expeditiously so that the trial could
begin as scheduled and in the Nixon case
the court granted certain issued an
opinion just 16 days later in part so
that one of the Watergate criminal
trials could proceed Smith argues that
quote this is a quintessential example
of an important question federal law
that has not been but should be settled
by this court and the Supreme Court has
never directly addressed criminal
immunity even though it comes up every
time a sitting president orchestrates a
burglary has sex with an intern or tries
to overthrow the elected government and
Trump's lawyers responded by accusing
Jack Smith of trying to cancel Christmas
and scolding the special Council for
trying to make the court staff miserable
during the holidays that's not a joke
that's actually what they wrote in their
briefing quote it's as if the special
Council growled with his Grinch fingers
nervously drumming I must find some way
to keep Christmas from coming but how
now that's probably not what I would
write in my own Supreme Court briefing
but you got to hand it to him it's
memorable at least and Trump argues that
the March 2024 trial date itself is
unconstitutional and that the public
interest weighs strongly against the
request for expedited view Trump
contends that expedited consideration
would violate president Trump's due
process in Sixth Amendment rights among
others and he argues that it would
deprive him of the time necessary to
prepare his defense since the case
includes 11.5 million pages of Discovery
though this does ignore an important
fact which is that the immunity issue is
largely a matter of law not fact and if
the Supreme Court agrees with Trump that
he is immune from prosecution then
there's no need to read the 11.5 million
pages of documents because the case
would be over and the Supreme Court
quickly agreed to expedite consideration
of of Smith's petition now this is not
the same thing as agreeing to decide the
case before the appeals court makes a
decision this is a decision to decide
whether to decide that case UPF front
and Smith is taking nothing for granted
he can currently filed a motion to
expedite proceedings in the DC circuit
asking for an expedited schedule that
will ensure that a decision is made fast
enough that the Supreme Court would hear
it during the current term the DC
federal appeals court granted the
government's request to expedite
consideration of Trump's appeal and the
appeals court has set deadlines for
briefs to be filed between December 23rd
and January 2nd now what about the
merits of the case well American
Presidents enjoy absolute immunity from
most civil lawsuits involving conduct
that occurred during their presidential
terms the Constitution does not
explicitly say that the president
actually has any litigation immunity
because of his role as chief executive
but this immunity exists by judicial
interpretation and in practice it means
that a president is given the freedom to
exercise His official duties without
being exposed to litigation for civil
damages and in Nixon versus Fitzgerald a
5 to4 Supreme Court ruled that a
president is entitled to to Absolute
immunity from legal liability for civil
damages based on his official Acts
including acts on the Outer Perimeter of
his duties the court defined the
president's official duties quite
broadly to prevent future presidents
from being sued for quote virtually
every allegation that an action was
unlawful or was taken for a forbidden
purpose now the Contours of immunity
from civil liability are still being
defined in Clinton vers Jones the
Supreme Court gave Paul Jones the green
light to sue Bill Clinton for sexual
harassment that happened before he was
president and when Ean Carrol sued Trump
for defamation after he said that she
lied about sexual assault he asserted
that he had immunity because he called
her a liar while he was president and
his statements were included in the
Outer Perimeter of His official duties
but last week the second Circuit Court
of Appeals ruled that Trump waved
immunity the first time a court has held
the presidential immunity was wable and
Trump also raised immunity as a defense
to lawsuits filed by Capital police
officers and members of Congress who
assert that Trump incited a riot on
January 6 but a three-judge panel of the
DC circuit rejected this claim the Court
held that Trump's remarks on that day
were not necessarily within the Outer
Perimeter of His official acts it's
possible that they were and it's
possible that they weren't that will
have to be decided at trial and when he
acts outside of the functions of his
office he does not continue to enjoy
immunity from damages liability just
because he happens to be president
rather as the Supreme Court made clear
in Clinton versus Jones a president's
official act immunity by Nature does not
extend to his unofficial actions when he
acts in an unofficial private capacity
he is subject to civil suits like any
private citizen but the bigger question
is what about criminal liability for
acts which occur during the presid
presidency now Donald Trump wants the
same circuit court that decided the
capital police case to rule that he
can't be criminally prosecuted for
anything he did well president now no
court has ever ruled that a sitting
president is immune from all criminal
liability while President however Trump
is arguing a school of thought known as
the unitary executive Theory and this
theory was largely developed by anonin
skilia while he served in the Nixon
Administration now according to this
Theory every Power not expressly granted
to the Judiciary or the legislature is
given to the president as part of his
duties to Faithfully execute the law and
AOS postulates that the entire federal
government serves at the command of the
president neither Congress nor the
courts have a right to check the
president's orders and there are some
Scholars that extend the unitary
executive Theory to make the president
immune from Criminal prosecution however
there have been some roadblocks to this
idea for example in 20120 the Supreme
Court ruled against Trump's version of
the unitary executive theory in a case
where he challenged New York's right to
subpoena his business records for
alleged Financial crimes in Trump versus
Vance the court rejected the proposition
that sitting president uh can use his
powers under article the Constitution to
assert immunity from criminal
investigation then in Trump versus mzar
the Supreme Court ruled that the
president wasn't immune from
congressional subpoenas investigation is
different from prosecution though the
justice department has long taken the
position that a sitting president could
be investigated but not charged with a
crime until after he leaves office this
is why Robert Mueller's team prosecuted
Trump's Associates but did not charge
Trump with crimes though the Justice
Department's reasoning doesn't have the
force of law and the analysis is a bit
shaking however even the doj agrees that
a president can be be prosecuted after
his term ends but forign president Trump
has gone a step further in asserting
that a former president can never face
criminal prosecution for acts that they
did well president unless they were
impeached and convicted uh in Congress
now judge chuckin has rejected this out
of hand quote The Constitution's text
structure in history do not support that
contention no court or any other branch
of government has ever accepted it and
this court will not so hold whatever
immunities a sitting president may enjoy
the United States has only one chief
executive at a time and that position
does not for a lifelong get out of jail
free pass former presidents enjoy no
special conditions on their Federal
Criminal liability defendant may be
subject to federal investigation
indictment prosecution conviction and
punishment for any criminal acts
undertaken while in office and in Nixon
versus Fitz cherl the Supreme Court
previously affirmed that there is no
provision in the Constitution conferring
criminal immunity and a memo from the
Department of Justice's office of legal
council confirms that quote the
Constitution provides no explicit
immunity from Criminal sanctions for any
civil officer including the current
president and it appears the framers of
the Constitution included immunity for
other Federal officials such as members
of Congress who are protected by the
speech and debate clause but they didn't
give this kind of immunity to the
president and as for Trump's assertion
that the impeachment judgment Clause
grants him immunity uh this Clause says
quote judgment in cases of impeachment
shall not extend further than to removal
from office and disqualification to hold
and enjoy any office of Honor trust or
profit under the United States but the
party convicted shall nevertheless be
liable and subject to indictment trial
judgment and Punishment according to law
now Trump says this means that he can't
be indicted convicted or punished unless
the Senate convicted him at his
impeachment trial uh judge chuckin so
far has said that the first part of the
Clause was meant to distinguish the
presidency from British tradition in
which an impeachment conviction could
result in additional penalties like
fines and even execution and the second
part of the impeachment Clause that says
the party convicted shall nevertheless
be liable and subject to indictment
trial judgment and Punishment according
to law uh judge tucking concluded that
this means that further punishment by
the courts is possible Trump argues that
it's only possible if the president is
in fact convicted during impeachment and
while Trump's argument already has
traction with Justice Alo who discussed
it in The Descent in Trump versus Vance
judge chuckin wrote that even if Trump's
interpretation was valid it would only
protect the president while he was in
office which has been the olc's position
since the Nixon era and Trump's argument
would undermine accountability for other
lawbreaking officials because it would
quote apply not only to the president
but also the vice president and all
civil officers of the United States who
may likewise be impeached and the order
discusses the history of criminality by
executive officials Vice President Aaron
Burr was indicted even though his
impeachment trial did not end in
conviction vice president sparo agnu was
indicted despite not being impeached and
eventually resigning and entering a no
contest plea and in one of the more
ridiculous incidences in presidential
history President Grant was cited for
reckless driving of horses uh and then
the next day he did it again an officer
arrested and fined Grant but Grant did
not argue that he was immune from
prosecution prior cases deciding issues
of presidential immunity address the
Article 2 interest of the presidency for
example Nixon versus Fitzgerald was
about a president allegedly injuring
individuals who had to sue for damages
but both the doj's legal team and the
Trump legal team are going to need a lot
of coffee over the holidays to write
their briefs do right before Christmas
and right after New Year's luckily they
can get some great coffee from today's
sponsor Trade coffee trade's great
because not only do they have a huge
selection of your favorite coffees but
they have a fine-tuning matching process
that helps you discover fresh coffee
based on your taste preferences oh hey
and this holiday season trade is the
perfect gift for any coffee lover
there's two ways you can gift trade you
can gift a subscription or a gift box
like this one uh for coffee subscription
all you have to do is choose how much
you want to spend meaning the number of
bags of coffee that your friend or loved
one will receive and then you can
personalize the rest with trades coffee
quiz or you can get a coffee gift box I
can personally tell you that the gift
boxes are amazing I got one with
chocolate chili and caramel syrup
usually caramel syrup tastes like
artificial goo but this stuff is so
incredible I'm actually surprised that
there's any of it left because I was
fully willing to Swig it directly and
then the bag of coffee it came with was
great it matched the syrups perfectly
now I have very specific tastes in
coffee I basically want something that
tastes like hot chocolate and pairs well
with milk and trade is always able to
find me the perfect bean and let's be
honest you claim you want a rich dark
roast but you really want a coffee
milkshake but either way trade has you
covered and if you already know what you
like then they probably already have
your favorite rooster in stock at a
great price you can even choose whole
beans or your preferred grind you can
get it delivered straight to your door
or straight to the door of a lucky
friend or loved one so if you love
coffee or are looking for a great gift
this holiday season try Trade coffee all
you have to do is click on the link in
the description or the one that's on
screen right now and not only will you
get your first bag free you'll also get
free shipping so get your first bag free
by clicking on the link on screen and of
course you have all the gift bag and
gift subscription options too so click
on the link to check it out after that
click on this link over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court